to explain what we are
doing we are preparing clinics
to seem to go more than 100 people
every day
in the parties outside of santo domingo with
a bat it is an area that started by the
sugar companies they are small towns
most of them do not have electricity or
water  current
and people
are working in a level of poverty that
I never said in my life
what we do is prepare a clinic
in a school or a church or something like that
completely to start
registration and
and vital
and a clinic and behind a pharmacy
and  We try to be there every day to read more
or less 100 120 people, between children from
one month old to adults over 90
years old, people were a little
worried because we were there,
we are from a church or something
like that, but it was not a surprise that  we are
from such a big company that we are
doing this service
for free obviously but
the heart was not clear because of the people
living in the cakes
is nothing more  that we want to help
people from all over the world who have these
places in honduras and the dominican republic
after building the big clinic
to do surgery
and also that we are going to see more people
but we are not going to stop going to the
pates and preparing  the clinic in
changes
[Music]